plan de relance à qui que ce soit parce
que de toute façon tous l'exécutif gère
l'urgence une fois que l'urgence sera
derrière nous c'est à dire qu'on aura
commencé à contenir
l'épidémie à ce moment-là les plans de
relance qui seront activés seront des
plans de relance à mon avis très
exactement à l'identique sauf à ce que
les gens qui sont l'objet des plans de
relance et eux-mêmes des demandes pour
se relancer de façon un peu plus verte
et qu'ils y ait pensé à l'avance et dans
un troisième temps seulement ce qui est
en train d'être éventuellement pensé
aujourd'hui
sera discutable
au moment où la relance elle-même
s'essoufflera parce que il est
vraisemblable que on est un problème
avec la relance elle-même alors c'est là
que je vais venir à un autre question
donc je vais faire un petit
aller-retour sur la question pétrole et
CO2
parce que j'ai vu que la question avait
été posée également
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce
moment sur le pétrole
une des explications que j'ai entendu
c'est que nous sommes déjà en fait dans
la prépique et que on est déjà en train
de vivre une situation de déflation et
que cette situation a été engendrée par
le choc pétrolier qui s'est étalé de
2008 à 2014 et qui lui-même a été
provoqué par le pic de production du
pétrole conventionnel alors je le refais
dans l'ordre 2008 nous dit l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie le pétrole
conventionnel passe par un pic du coup
on a ce qu'il est coutume d'appeler
maintenant la crise des subprimes mais
en fait est une crise énergétique à la
base d'abord le pétrole commence à se
faire un peu plus rare ou plus
exactement il augmente plus le PIB
décélère et le système financier
américain se détricote
là dedans le prix du pétrole remonte
très fortement du coup les
investissements dans la mont pétrolier
triple en l'espace de quelques années on
racle un peu mieux les fonds de tiroirs
et surtout on se met à lancer la
production de chez lloy mais laquelle
est beaucoup plus difficile
techniquement et beaucoup moins rentable
économiquement que la production de
pétrole qui conventionnel qui elle est
en train de décliner et le système en
novembre 2018 arrive un pic depuis
lequel la production décline et ce pic
engendre lui-même un début de difficulté
économique on voyait bien la croissance
était en train de baisser partout la
production industrielle de l'Allemagne a
commencé à souffrir etc et ce pic
engendre un début de diminution du prix
du pétrole et à ce moment le système
s'emballe le début de diminution du prix
du pétrole mais les Foreurs de chez
l'oeil en difficulté supprime encore
plus les investissements et là-dessus
arrive le coronavirus qui est le coût de
grâce en faisant tomber le du baril à un
niveau qui est tellement bas que les
investissements vont continuer à baisser
alors là dessus qu'est-ce qui va se
passer il va se passer que comme les
investissements dans le sheil qui était
le seul réservoir de croissance avec les
sables bitumineux baisse du coup la
production de chez l'oeil va s'arrêter
de croître voir se mettre à baisser dans
les pronostics qu'on commence à voir
passer ici et là il y avait un article
je sais plus dans le FTI je crois
aujourd'hui
10 ans que 2020 pourraient très pour
être très bien à 30 ou 40 dollars le
baril être l'année du pic de production
du shelloy à ce moment la production
mondiale de pétrole se met à baisser et
comme l'activité économique suit au
premier ordre ou plus exactement ne peut
pas être plus importante c'est plutôt ça
qu'il faut voir
que la production de pétrole c'est il
peut y avoir autre chose qu'il entame
par exemple le coronavirus mais en tout
cas ça ça borne supérieure son enveloppe
c'est la quantité de pétrole disponible
et comme cette quantité baisse ça veut
dire que la reprise les plans de reprise
ne donneront pas les effets c'est là que
je voulais en venir dit autrement à un
moment on retombe sur un défaut de
pétrole pour que les plans de relance
s'appliquent à plein et donc ce qui va
se passer c'est qu'on va injecter plein
d'argent c'est un peu comme le
Quantitative Easing après 2008 on va
injecter plein d'argent et la relance
économique ne suivra pas donc c'est à ce
moment-là et à ce moment-là seulement
que peut-être il commencera à y avoir
une opportunité pour que les oreilles
s'ouvrent et qu'on essaye de faire
différemment alors ce différemment il
demande des des comment dire il demande
des mesures qu'il a aussi pour le moment
sont très très peu disponibles sur la
table
parce que en gros ça revient à faire
face à des problèmes qui augmentent avec
des moyens qui baissent or personne
aujourd'hui y compris chez les
écologistes c'est ça qui est très drôle
personne aujourd'hui n'a ce type de
cahier des charges en tête si on prend
nos amis de mégawatt par exemple la
contrepartie économique de leur scénario
c'est la croissance c'est-à-dire que
quand ils ont fait le volet économique
de la scénario ça se fait dans un monde
en croissance la SNBC française qui
prévoit une très forte baisse de la
consommation d'énergie fossiles enfin
obligatoirement qui scénarisent pas
prévoir une très forte baisse de la
consommation d'énergie fossiles et bien
elle se fait dans le cadre d'un monde en
croissance le scénario 2 degré de la i.e
qui est aussi un scénario qui est censé
permettre d'avoir une économie qui se
décarbonne se fait dans un monde en
décroissance en croissance par contre
et
le green dit l'Européen
se pense également dans un monde en
croissance donc aujourd'hui sur la table
à dessin il n'y a pas de plan pour gérer
un monde avec moins de moyens dit
autrement les gens qui ont pensé des
mesures activables dans un monde dans
lequel globalement les moyens baisse et
je parle bien des moyens physiques dont
les moyens économiques ne sont qu'une
représentation mais dans un monde dans
lequel des moyens physiques baissent
pour le moment les gens qui ont tenté
d'y réfléchir sont en comment dire rare
aussi project c'est ça qu'on essaye de
faire soit dit en passant on a déjà
essayé de réfléchir en ce sens et on va
à la faveur de ce qui est en train de
nous arriver essayez d'accoucher d'une
espèce de crash programme ou de plans
qu'on pourrait proposer dont on ne pense
pas qu'il sera encore une fois audible
dans les mois qui viennent mais par
contre on espère vraiment que dans les
dans l'année
de contre maintenant et la prochaine
élection présidentielle si la situation
dégénère pas trop
on aura une fenêtre de tir pour le
présenter parce que encore une fois je
pense que malheureusement la réalité
c'est que quand il y aura des plans de
relance ces plans de relance vont buter
sur la baisse de la production de
pétrole alors accessoirement au moment
où il y aura des plans de relance et une
production de pétrole en baisse la
logique voudrait qu'il y ait un nouveau
choc pétrolier c'est à dire qu'à ce
moment-là le prix du pétrole remonte
très rapidement comme vous avez pu le
constater ces derniers temps le prix du
pétrole est devenu maintenant
extrêmement volatile donc il est capable
de fluctuer à la hausse comme à la
baisse
très très rapidement et donc je ne serai
pas plus étonné que ça si après être à
20 dollars le baril un an après ou deux
ans après il se baladait à 100 dollars
le baril je pense que tout ça fait
partie des choses possibles donc je suis
pas du tout en train de faire une
prévision je suis juste en train de dire
que c'est très très difficile
aujourd'hui
de faire des pronostics et plus que
jamais cette blague de pétrolier me est
valable qui est vous pouvez donner un
prix et vous pouvez donner une date mais
surtout jamais les deux en même temps
voilà donc le le pétrole va être un
facteur limitant de la reprise alors
après est-ce que ça veut dire que le
pétrole de schiste américain va voir sa
bulle éclatée
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle une pile ce
qui me paraît clair c'est que le pétrole
est tellement stratégique pour les
États-Unis que je pense que les
États-Unis vont soutenir leur pétrolier
par tous les moyens possibles y compris
en demandant aux actionnaires et au
prêteurs de s'asseoir sur la montagne de
dettes ce que les pétroliers ont
contracté c'est-à-dire que le scénario
le plus probable pour moi c'est pas que
les Foreurs de pétrole de schiste font
faillite et que du coup il y a plus de
pétrole qui sort je pense que s'il y a
un problème d'approvisionnement les
Foreurs font faillite et ils repartent
comme comme en 40 derrière tout
simplement parce que vous savez qu'aux
États-Unis comme en France il y a une
loi sur les redressements judiciaires le
chapter eleven aux Etats-Unis qui permet
de de redémarrer l'activité à l'abri de
ses créanciers donc je pense que
c'est la production elle-même elle sera
limitée aux États-Unis beaucoup plus par
des facteurs géologiques et techniques
que par des facteurs financiers le chez
l'oeil il a pas gagné d'argent en cash
flow depuis ses origines ça ne l'empêche
pas d'avoir continué à produire de plus
en plus je suis pas complètement
convaincu que il va s'arrêter de
produire tout simplement parce qu'il a
des difficultés économiques aujourd'hui
qui peut pas rembourser ses créanciers
je pense que du point de vue des
États-Unis c'est pas complètement un
sujet donc est-ce que le la bulle va
éclater au sens où il va y avoir de la
dette pourrie qui sera pas remboursé ça
très vraisemblablement est-ce que ça va
empêcher les producteurs de chez l'oeil
de produire c'est pas sûr est-ce que ça
va avoir un effet systémique sur
l'économie je ne crois pas parce que ça
représente un paquet de dettes mais ça
représente un beaucoup plus petit paquet
de dettes que la tête des états donc je
pense que ça et c'est beaucoup plus
petit que le crédit immobilier qui a mis
le feu aux poudres en 2008 donc je ne
suis pas complètement sûr que ça soit un
risque systémique
par contre je le redis ce que je crois
c'est que la baisse des investissements
d'une manière générale dans le monde a
pas qu'aux États-Unis avec un pétrole à
20 ou 30 dollars va avoir un effet sur
la production on peut rajouter à ça le
fait que un des producteurs majeurs
aujourd'hui qui est la Russie avait
annoncé avant l'épisode coronavirus et
avant l'épisode pétrole à 20 dollar que
ils escomptaient passer leur pic en 2021
alors personne ne saura jamais si c'est
du bluff en fonction sera après coup
comme d'habitude mais s'il y a un début
de réalité à ça ça veut dire que il faut
effectivement s'attendre dans les années
qui viennent à des soubresauts très
importants et je le redis au fait que le
plan de relance en business asusual va
se heurter de toute façon au mur du
pétrole et que c'est à ce moment là
qu'il faudra être prêt avec des
propositions concrètes pour ne pas que
la population soit laissée dans un
désarroi qui alors là sera extrêmement
extrêmement élevé
un autre effet que ça va avoir le
[Musique]
il y a quelqu'un qui le dit c'est pas le
coronavirus qui fait tomber le prix du
baril c'est une conjonction qui fait
tomber le prix du baril c'est-à-dire
c'est à la fois le coronavirus le fait
que on était déjà en économie qui
commençait à se déprimer et le fait
effectivement que les Russes et les
Saoudiens ont décidé de ne pas baisser
les vannes pour de ne pas oui fermer les
vannes pour autant c'est une conjonction
de l'ensemble
ce qui
[Musique]
donc je disais ce qui va être
intéressant
c'est de concevoir des plans de relance
qui peuvent passer la rampe alors une
des choses qui pourrait très bien se
produire soit dit en passant dans ce
contexte là c'est que le soutien aux
énergies renouvelables électriques qui
aujourd'hui consomment des grandes
quantités de capitaux et qui s'occupent
d'un problème notamment en France qui
n'était pas urgent fasse l'objet d'une
réorientation rapide voilà ça c'est
quelque chose qui on voyait déjà les
Allemands qui étaient en train de caler
l'année dernière ils ont installé
beaucoup moins d'éolien dans l'année que
ce qu'il faisait les années précédentes
alors par contre ils ont installé pas
mal de solaire mais il est pas du tout
il est pas du tout exclu que l'un des
effets collatéraux j'ai envie de dire de
cette affaire là c'est que la perfusion
d'argent public qui est nécessaire pour
le déploiement de ces trucs là soit
ce tarif et c'est d'autant plus possible
que il peut y avoir un effet étonnant dû
au marché aujourd'hui les tarifs
garantis finances un delta entre le prix
de marché la différence entre le prix de
marché et le coût de production
si on a une économie déprimée les prix
de marché devraient logiquement baisser
et donc le la quantité d'argent
nécessaire au soutien financier devrait
à ce moment-là augmenter donc si les
prix de marché deviennent durablement
bas parce que l'économie en a pris un
grand coup dans le nez et bien c'est
quelques on peut très bien avoir un
enchaînement moins de pétrole du coup
l'économie souffre ou coronavirus du
coup l'économie souffre et du coup
derrière la demande électrique baisse et
à ce moment les prix de l'électricité
deviennent durablement bas et donc
paradoxalement comme pour le moment les
unr sont toujours prioritaires sur le
réseau la quantité d'argent public qu'il
faut pour soutenir cette filière
augmente voilà ça sera intéressant de
regarder ce qui va se passer dans ce
domaine là dans les mois et les années
qui qui viennent
alors dans les questions corolaires
toujours sur le pétrole
il y avait une question qui était
pourquoi est-ce que les dirigeants
européen ne sont pas plus inquiets que
cela face au futur difficulté
d'approvisionnement pétrole ça rejoint
une autre question qu'on m'avait posé
une fois qui est pourquoi est-ce que on
peut manquer de pétrole et ne pas voir
dans le prix
la réponse en fait c'est la même réponse
aux deux questions c'est tout simplement
que comme il n'y a pas d'élasticité long
terme entre le pétrole et son prix entre
la quantité de pétrole disponible et son
prix et que les dirigeants ne
surveillent que le prix en fait ils
pensent que tant que le prix est bas
c'est qu'on n'a pas de problème
d'approvisionnement ils ne comprennent
pas qu'un prix bas peut signifier qu'on
a eu un problème d'approvisionnement
avant et que ça a cassé l'économie ils
comprennent pas ça de même que quand on
se dit si le pétrole coûte pas cher à la
pompe c'est qu'il y en a assez pour tout
le monde en fait quand on se dit ça on
ne comprend pas que un défaut de pétrole
a déjà pu casser l'économie et à ce
moment il y a juste moins de gens qui
ont les moyens de rouler en voiture et
donc c'est normal que à la pompe le
pétrole vaille pas plus cher parce que
la demande l'offre a changé mais la
demande a projet aussi donc les gens en
Europe ils sont intimement persuadés et
que les marchés étant parfait si on doit
manquer de pétrole le prix augmente à
définiement et tant que le prix
n'augmente pas indéfiniment c'est qu'on
manque pas de pétrole voilà c'est ça le
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils sont
pas ils sont pas inquiets